gpt3 is a bit like a chicken and an egg
problem
so is it creative on its own or is it
creative in tandem with human prompting
well I mean
I I think that that question is a
question of taste right I mean you know
if you think of human creativity you
know there's nothing new Under the Sun
right so if I generate if I make a
beautiful new painting and everyone
admires it well to what extent am I
simply an inheritor of artistic
Traditions or ideas that I have I have
seen
I think you know exactly the same
framework is how we should think about
language models right so they are
trained on they're trained they're
pre-trained on large volumes of data
they're often then fine-tuned on much
more specific data or perhaps with
reinforcement learning or an equivalent
method and so of course
what they are capable of doing is a
product of what they have experienced
just like it is for us
[Music]